on our top story now and that prisoner
exchange between Ukraine and a Russian
separatist there in the east of the
country that's what has begun it's the
second major release since Kiev and
Moscow agreed to exchange detainees in
September Alexander got freud is live
for us in moscow another significant
development Alexandra and a positive
step forward in terms of de-escalating
the situation yet it is still tense
isn't it yes of course I mean we have a
daily reports of the fire exchanges here
and there in these territories but what
is going on at this moment is a
significant step forward what is
actually going on at this point is that
at the checkpoint of my arrest which is
near a town of horlivka demarcation line
between Ukraine and the russian-backed
separatists there at this point swapping
the prisoners they will have to do the
identification of the people meaning to
match the person presented with the name
on the list
and what we do not know at this point is
exact number of people that is going to
be swapped what was agreed was all known
for all known and according to
representatives of the separatists from
Donetsk area they're saying they're
giving away handing over rather 55
people and expecting from Kiev 87 but
the exact number is at this point not
known
also from the Kiev side this list is
actually specifically interesting
because yesterday there was an
information that they're going to
include in this exchange 5x members of
the special police forces that were
involved or a rather accused of shooting
people in 2014 on the square of the
independence in Kiev and these are the
events that took place before the
annexation of Crimea
before the first gun was ever fired in
the east of Ukraine so what we are
seeing now is a second big exchange this
year but the first one in September that
you mentioned was between the states of
Russia and Ukraine and such a prisoner
exchange that is happening at this
moment happened last time two years ago
exactly at this same checkpoint of
mayorsk and of course while we see this
sort of movement on the ground on the
diplomatic level Alexandre we see
presidents Putin and Solinsky
respectively saying to each other that
they want to try and deescalate all of
this scenario by 2020 but this
sovereignty of Crimea will continue to
rumble on so even if you do have
prisoner swaps it doesn't ease the issue
of sanctions that have been applied by
the European Union and the United States
and that is a diplomatic scenario that
has yet to be solved yes exactly and not
only that this prisoner swap has been
agreed on the meeting in the beginning
of December between in the Normandy
format but also in a face-to-face
meeting of Russian and Ukrainian
presidents Putin and zelanski but what
is to happen now is even more
challenging when it comes to the
conflict in the East Ukraine that
claimed 13,000 lives so far that had
seen million people fled their homes and
that is the elections that should happen
according to Ukrainian law in this
Russian backed separatists area but also
the control of the over the border with
Russia which Ukraine doesn't have since
2014 and this is exactly the point that
even in this meeting the two sides
didn't manage to agree because Ukraine
says we want to control our border first
and then this areas can get the
elections whilst Putin says but that's
not what the previous President signed
in 2015 in Minsk that first the
elections should happen and then the
process of taking over the control over
the border should start so it is hard to
say whether this will indeed bring the
peace to this area and how forward this
will this will move the situation indeed
will continue to follow events on the
ground certainly where that prisoner
swap is happening and come back to you
through the day thank you